Das war's für heute. Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute. Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Das war's für heute. Vielen Dank.
Das ist ein Taschenrechner. Das ist ein halbes Smartphone.
Das ist ein Taschenrechner.
Warum hab ich auf einem Taschenrechner ein Menü, wo Network und Login drinsteht?
Auf der anderen Seite haben wir auch unsere Steckdose geflasht letztens.
Und haben sogar ein Web-Interface für eine Steckdose.
Die größte Veränderung war das unterliegende Hardware. Die TI-83 und TI-85 haben Z80-Prozessoren. Die TI-89 und TI-92 haben ein Upgrade zum Motorola 68000. Inspire wurde aber von ARM-CPUs. Die waren dramatischer.
Das hat Enthusiastes Aufmerksamkeit in einer großen Art. Anstatt einen kompakten, effizienten Kod auf unterliegenden Hardware zu fahren, konnten sie nun die Freiheit haben, sich über die Existenz von ARM-Based-Software zu portieren.
Texas Instruments fiel eine Kurveballe mit der Inspire-Serie. Die Anleitung war nicht gefunden. Inspire Modelle erlaubten nur, Programme in Basics oder in einer Sprache wie Lua zu schreiben.
Lua oder Basics? Dann eher Lua.
Die Taschenrechner waren doch sehr teuer. Wir gucken mal. Wie heißt das?
Inspire. Ja krass.
Ach es geht eigentlich. Geht eigentlich.
150 Euro. Klar, da kriegt man ein Einsteiger-Smartphone für. Aber immerhin, geht doch eigentlich. Ja, die jailbreakenden Taschenrechner, wenn ich das so richtig sehe, hast du recht, der ohne Kohle.
Okay, also, wie auf IOS.
Quake auf dem Taschenrechner.
Minecraft auf dem Taschenrechner. Warum? Na ja, weil es geht, was sonst?
Päggle, oder was ist das?
Der Nebulator auf dem Taschenrechner. Na gut, wenn da eine halbwegs aktuelle Arm-CPU drin ist, warum nicht?
Ein 0,5 FPS.
Klar, sogar mein Drucker kann Doom.
Calculator im Calculator. Das ist wirklich cool, das ist nice.
Man beachtet mal, wie schnell sich der Bild und wie schnell der Bildaufbau ist hier.
Nee, so rum.
Auf dem Taschenrechner, geiles Zeug.
Das finde ich natürlich voll das Geile.
Geil.
Das Ding sieht aus wie ein Review von vor 20 Jahren.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist schon geil. Flixcoder verstehe ich auch nicht.
Was Texas Instruments dagegen hat, dass man seine Taschenrechner moddet, weil letztendlich kann ich doch scheißegal, sie haben das Ding verkauft.
Doch, es ist ja nicht so, dass die irgendwie von neuen Apps leben würden oder so.
Das ist ein Taschenrechner.
Nee, wir wollten das Video von Serious Max gucken.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, das hat nichts mit Overwatch zu tun, das geht um Fallout.
150 Euro Taschenrechner an Schulen? Na ja, das muss ja nicht an der Schule sein, das kann auch an der Uni sein oder so.
Also in der Schule, wir hatten da mal so einen ganz komischen, was? Casio, irgendwas.
Die Richtung sah der aus, plus das meine hat einen gelben Knopf. Eine Sharp, war das ein Sharp vielleicht?
Eher so in die Richtung. Egal, aber Taschenrechner, wer braucht sowas heute schon, oder? Was Fallout 76 ist mega unterhaltsam.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, geht um Fallout.
Hat ja nicht geguckt. 8 Millionen Aufrufe, 350.000 Likes. Das Rest waren hier die Bethesda Fake Accounts, die Daumen untergegeben haben.
Wir mussten uns die Dinge auch selbst kaufen an der Schule damals, aber das war nicht so teuer.
Also das war jetzt nicht so der High-End-Taschenrechner, aber hat damals glaube ich auch 50, 50, da haben wir wahrscheinlich noch Mac gekostet.
Das war damals übelst viel Kohle für mich, bzw. für meine Mutter.
Ich ruf Schmack so mal nebenbei, weil ich mein, alleinerziehend und nicht so viel Kohle halbtags gearbeitet, da gab es nicht so viel Geld.
Aber jetzt ist ja Easy Money, Easy Life angesagt.
Ok, als Steuerbereiter verstehe ich, dass man da ein Rechner braucht.
Das ist auch besser als auf irgendeinem Rechner rumtippen, da willst du direkt was haben, wo du drauf tippen kannst.
Ja, das verstehe ich. Leuchtet ein.
Ich kann mich dran erinnern, als sie das angekündigt haben, sind alle Fallout-Fans übelst ausgeflippt und ich finde damals sah das schon übelst kacke aus.
Das ist was, was der Marketing Dude sagt, wenn er keine Ahnung hat, was er eigentlich sagen soll.
Das sagste einfach mal irgendwie ne große Zahl.
Was? Wie viel? So viel hab ich noch nicht gesehen, Moment.
Alter, 50, ok, 45 Gigabyte, das ist so groß wie Titanfall 1 komplett und Titanfall 1 war schon sinnlos groß, weil sie das Audio nicht komprimiert hatten damals.
Das ist wie Battlefield 4 mit allen DLCs und Maps zusammen.
Am besten war allerdings immer noch dieses eine Tony Hawk Game, was rausgekommen ist auf der Xbox 360.
Da hatten sie es nämlich so gemacht, dass, egal, ich find's nicht, da hatten sie es so gemacht, dass auf der CD oder auf der DVD, die man gekaufen konnte, war bloß das Tutorial drauf.
Und da du das Spiel spielen konntest, musst du dich Xbox Live verbinden und Day One-Patch runterladen, der in Wirklichkeit das ganze Spiel war.
Richtig debatet.
Ok, wahl weiter.
Oh.
Hahaha, defunct.
Gut, nice.
Cool.
Scheint ja gut zu laufen.
Was?
Ernsthaft?
WTF, wie unfähig kann man sein?
Ich mein, das ist ja dann aber wirklich 0 an 15 Basic für jede etwas größere Web-Anwendung, die unterschiedliche User hat.
Und du kannst dich nicht in andere Accounts einloggen, es sei denn, du kriegst das Passwort von dem, aber anscheinend war es ja so, du hast dich eingeloggt mit deinem Account und auf einmal landest du in einem anderen Account.
WTF?
Mein Tor noch kurz was trinken, Schlossball auf.
Hahaha.
Ich geh jetzt mal davon aus, das ist nicht ausgedacht, das ist echt so passiert.
Ach du Scheiße.
Das Review hab ich geklappt.
Haha.
Wer hättet das gedacht, hä?
Wer hättet das gedacht, kommt ja heutzutage nie vor.
Wahrscheinlich haben sie selbst festgestellt, dass ihr Geld der übelste Crap ist, da haben sie sich gedacht, ey komm lass den Scheiß raushauen, bevor wir da noch mehr Geld ausgeben und dann versuchen wir irgendwie die Leute ein bisschen noch das Geld raus zu pressen.
Hat aber inzwischen nicht so gut geklappt.
Haha.
Hahaha.
Sag mal, wenn ich das jetzt, ich mein wir sind jetzt erst 6 Minuten in diesem Video, ja?
Wir sind erst 6 Minuten drinne.
Ich hab das Spiel nicht gespielt, ich hab nur den Trailer geguckt.
Ich fand das erste was sie gezeigt haben schon blöd, aber ok.
Wir sind 6 Minuten in dem Video.
Also erst ein Fünftel oder so von dem Video.
Quickmaps, ein Viertel von dem Video.
Was ich bis jetzt vor dem Spiel gesehen hab, kann das sein, dass das einfach absolut komplett kaputt ist.
Also nicht einfach nur kaputt, sondern undurchdacht kaputt, verbuggt, ohne jegliches Konzept dahinter.
Ohne durchdachtes Gameplay, ohne irgendwie durchdachtes Spielwert, nichts.
Also einfach so ein komplett dahingeschissenes Produkt irgendwie.
Genau, ok.
Hat aber das jetzt richtig verstanden anscheinend.
Nicht dass ich jetzt gebunkert tost werde.
Was? Moment, was?
Oh Gott, ist das schlecht.
Vor allem, wenn das was ist, wo man nicht will, dass die Leute es erreichen, dann sollte man das vielleicht gar nicht in-game einbauen,
beziehungsweise überhaupt so gestalten, dass es funktioniert.
Und nicht einfach eine Wand, wo man durchklemmt.
Ach du Scheiße.
Halt fest.
Da sind sie aber nicht die ersten, die das gemacht haben.
In irgendeinem anderen Online-Multiplayer-Game, war das nicht sogar DayZ oder DayZ oder so?
Irgendwo haben sie das doch schon mal gemacht, wo du schreiben musstest, warum du ein böser Cheater bist.
Aber ich meine, in dem Fall ist es wirklich ein Witz.
Ich meine, das Game an sich ist es ja nicht so, dass das jetzt irgendwie funktionieren würde und ein paar hätten sich da krass eingehexort.
Wahrscheinlich hat diese Bannwelle auch übelst viele falsche Leute getroffen.
Warum, warum braucht, warum braucht ein Online-Game einen Dev Room, der auf dem Live-Server drauf ist?
Wollt ihr mal so, vorgefragt, warum muss das sein?
Das wissen die wahrscheinlich auch nicht so genau, warum das ist, warum das sein muss.
Mh.
Leute, die einige der besten Items im Spiel hatten.
Du hast 700 Stunden gebraucht, um die beste Waffe zu bekommen.
Tod, Cheater!
Dann haben sie ein System gelegt, in dem Spieler, wenn sie in den Raum kommen würden, getaggert werden.
Und dann haben sie diese Spieler gebannt.
Das war nicht viel besser, weil die Leute einfach mit Smurf-Accounts beginnen würden.
Gehen schnell mit einem Level-1-Account, mit all den guten Chats, dann aussteigen.
Dann benutzen sie einen Duplikations-Glitch, um mehr von diesen Items zu bekommen.
Dann transferieren sie das. Und du konntest auch noch Items dupen.
... zu deinem Haupt-Account, und du bist bereit zu gehen.
Bethesda nimmt dann diesen Level-1-Account aus und nennt ihn Mission Accomplished.
Und du hast das Spiel gewonnen.
So, das Problem ist weiter. Bethesda läuft aus Ideen, um es zu lösen.
Es gibt viele Spekulationen in der Medien zwischen den Spielern, wie genau die Menschen es geben.
Aber no one except for the exploiters knows for sure.
That said, Bethesda needs to act fast before it ruins the economy of the game.
So they wrote another email and sent it out to the Smurfs.
Hello cheater, do you want to tell us how you did it and we might unban you, please?
Should we not head back from you, the account will simply remain suspended.
It's not known whether this approach worked, but from what I've seen,
it's still possible to get into the dev room.
November 22nd, 2018, just a week after the release,
the game goes on discount.
From 60 to 40 dollars.
Alter, das ist schon bitter. Das ist schon bitter, das sagt alles.
Von full price zu 35 Dollar.
To 35, to 30.
You can find it for 15 on eBay, and in Germany,
they're straight up giving it for free when you buy a Playstation controller.
Also, some stores are just zip-tying it to other products.
But to Bethesda...
Du kannst dich gar nicht mal dagegen wehren.
So, nein, ich will das Game nicht.
Doch, du musst.
Nein, aber ich will das Game nicht.
Dann gibt's auch keine Xbox One.
Also, some stores are just zip-tying it to other products.
But to Bethesda, it's worth selling the thing at a price close to zero,
because it brings people into the Atomic Shop,
which is where you buy it, and it informs the poor sales figures.
Let's have a look at those.
The latest figures show 76 or less than a sixth of what Fallout 4 did.
Not good.
There's also been a massive oversupply of hard copies.
Although, what's the point of a hard copy
when the thing is just a cardboard disc
telling you to redeem an online code?
Das ist ja noch schlimmer als das Tony Hawk Game auf der Xbox,
wo nur die Demo auf der Disc war.
Da war wenigstens was auf der Disc.
And while sales are low, returns are high.
Immediately upon release, people began asking Bethesda for a refund.
76 is not on Steam.
It's on Bethesda's own platform.
So they have all the control.
If players only played the game for a few hours,
then generally they'd get their money back.
However, it came out that people were sometimes getting refunds
after a full 24 hours of playing.
Quite generous.
But then word about this spread to forums.
I love said comments.
The game is about 12,500 upvotes
informing people that this made pretty much everyone eligible for a refund.
And the comments told them exactly how to do it.
Bethesda was flooded with requests for refunds.
And their response?
Shut it down, lads.
No, no, no one gets a refund now.
Everyone go home, show's over.
Robot customer service man, engage.
Customers who have downloaded the game are not eligible for a refund.
We apologize.
Warum?
Ich mein,
Customers who have downloaded,
wenn du den Spiel gekauft hast
und reingucken willst,
um festzustellen, dass das Spiel sucked,
wie willst du das machen ohne zu downloaden?
Man hat davon abgesehen,
dass der Kram wahrscheinlich sogar automatisch anfängt zu downloaden.
We apologize for the inconvenience.
Ja, alles gut.
Kein Problem.
If there's anything else we can assist you,
please reply to the smith... Ja, ist klar.
...inconvenience.
Die EE, EE, EE.
A few things followed.
First people got mad.
One hardcore gamer even trashed a GameStop for refusing his refund.
Was geht mit dem ab?
Nein, das muss jetzt ja nicht sein, ne?
Der GameStop-Dude kann ja nix für.
Scheiße.
Das ist ja noch viel schlimmer, als ich das überhaupt mitgekriegt hab.
Das ist das Survival-Effekt.
Es hat ja jeder mitgekriegt, dass das Spiel komplett im Arsch ist, ja?
Aber das ist ja noch viel schlimmer, als ich mir das gedacht hab.
Und wisst ihr, wer wahrscheinlich am Endeffekt drunter leiden wird?
Das Team, was das unter diesen beschissenen Vorgaben und dem Spaß entwickeln musste.
Die haben wahrscheinlich die Arschkarte am Ende.
Wahrscheinlich wird das Studio dichtgemacht,
oder sie werden rausgeschmissen, oder sie kriegen keinen Bonus.
Sie haben wahrscheinlich die Arschkarte am Ende, ja?
Die Typen, die es entwickelt haben und wahrscheinlich ihr Bestes sogar noch gegeben haben.
Doch kann man so sagen, ja?
Fuck, das ist ja wirklich ein Ad. Ich dachte erst, das gehört zum Video dabei.
Wer hat noch gedacht, das gehört eigentlich zum Fallout-Video dabei?
Komm, wir gucken uns das an.
Ich mein, der Kerl hat sich Mühe gegeben mit 26 Minuten Video,
und das ist ein wirklich gutes Video, wie es aussieht.
Wir lassen jetzt auch seine Ads laufen.
Der Kerl hat sich Mühe gegeben mit 26 Minuten Video, und das ist ein wirklich gutes Video, wie es aussieht.
Der Modern Warfare Trailer und der Modern Warfare Trailer hat doch ganz gute, ganz gute Bewertung, oder?
Ja, saubermäßig gute Bewertung.
Infinity War hatte scheiß Bewertung, aber ich glaube nicht so schlecht. Was, ein bisschen lauter?
Oh Gott, kann ich das nicht sagen? Das ist mein eigenes Schild.
Es ist sehr dringend.
Oh Gott, das ist schlecht.
Moment Leute, wir gucken jetzt mal was. AliExpress, Nuka Cola, Bottle.
Es gibt keine Nuka Cola, Bottle und AliExpress, da bin ich jetzt aber enttäuscht. Also da bin ich von den Chinesen echt enttäuscht.
Aber es gibt hier nur andere.
Natürlich.
Ja, was sonst, was sonst.
Du hast immer die Leute, das finde ich eh bei vielen Sachen komplett lächerlich, du hast die Leute, die übelst, so die richtig hardcore Fanboys hast du immer.
Du musst quasi jeden Strohhalm nehmen, um irgendeine Firma zu feiern.
PSN ist kaputt, drei Tage am Stück und Sony schreibt dann irgendwie, ja, aber wir behaupten irgendwie so 0-15 Marketing-Tweet raus.
Ja, wir sind immer, unser Ziel ist es immer, die bestmöglichste Online-Erfahrung zu bieten. Hast du sofort die Fanboys am Start, so nach dem Motto, ja, was erwartet ihr auch von einem kostenlosen Service?
Naja gut, der Service ist dabei, wird beworben, ich erwarte, dass der funktioniert.
Also mittlerweile ist PSN nicht mehr kostenlos, ja mittlerweile kostet das was.
Es gibt immer so irgendwelche Fanboys am Start und es ist das dümmste, was du machen kannst, weil die Firma, also das Unternehmen an sich, die scheißt ja komplett auf diese Leute, es ist ja nicht mal als interessiert das dir jemand.
Das ist richtig dumm, so dieses ultra Fanboy von irgendwelchen Marken, von irgendwelchen Unternehmen, vor allem so grundlos Fanboy.
Der war sonst...
Oh, das ist ein bisschen unglückliches Wort auch.
Das ist ein glückliches Wort auch.
Alter, ist das denn Ihr Ernst, ist das für Leute, die Geld scheißen?
Für so eine Plastik-Jäckchen 276 Dollar?
Ja, aber die kannst du dir für 30 Euro kaufen.
Ups, habe ich das jetzt richtig gesehen?
Das Game hatte eine Multiplayer-Game mit Voice-Chat, hatte keine Push-to-Talk-Option.
Aber es brachte auch ein Feld-of-View-Slide.
Hooray!
Das ist ja fast wie bei Blizzard.
Time-Sync, Time-Sync.
Boah, Scheiße, ich hab mein Tee umgekippt.
Na klar, Timesync erhöhen, dass die Leute In-Game Zeug kaufen, weil spätestens jetzt
ist denen ja klar, das Game wird von sich keine großartige Kohle mehr abwerfen.
Jetzt muss man versuchen, die paar verliebenden Leute noch irgendwie so wie es geht in den
In-Game Shop oder möglichst viel im In-Game Shop aus den Leuten rauszudrücken.
Und der Hintergrund war wichtig, weil jeder wusste, warum die Thesda es machte. Um die Leute zu ermutigen, den Atomik-Shop zu benutzen.
Und jetzt reden wir kurz über diesen Stau.
Einige der Preise sind überraschend.
Ein Weihnachtstisch für 12 Dollar.
Ein Santa Outfit für 20 Dollar.
Eine gelbe Farbe für 18 Dollar.
18 Dollar, dass du deine Rüstung gelb färben kannst.
Da sind ja Black Ops 4 Skins und Gedüllens.
Oder wie heißt es Black Ops Black Market?
Ist ja nichts dagegen.
Das hier, Leute, das ist auch was, das finde ich...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das verboten werden soll, aber ich finde es auf jeden Fall fragwürdig.
Aber das machen alle so.
Und zwar das hier.
Das ist nicht off. Und das ist auch nicht limited.
Was, bitte schön, soll an einem In-Game Item limited sein?
Oder was soll an einem...
Wisst ihr was ich meine? Das ist total bescheuert.
Das ist einfach, wir generieren Fake Druck auf die Leute.
So nach dem Motto, es ist limited, nur 14 Tage.
Aber jetzt ist es doch, guck mal, es ist doch schon 50% billiger.
Deswegen müsste man jetzt eigentlich zuschlagen.
Das ist vor allem bei virtuellen Gegenstellen komplett aus der Luft gegriffen.
Und hat überhaupt keinerlei realitätsbezogene Grundlage.
Man kann das einfach drauf schreiben.
Das machen aber alle In-Game Shops. Und das finde ich...
Also das da, diese Limitertime und dieses auch, das finde ich fragwürdig.
Weil es bei virtuellen Items überhaupt keinen Sinn ergibt.
Das, oder?
Ja, genau, genau.
Das ist Skamars.
Das ist Hardcore Skamars.
Das ist doch krass Skamars.
Das machen aber viele In-Game Shops.
Das stimmt.
Richtig gutes Video.
Ist das Game mittlerweile halbwegs spielbar?
Ich habe das Game weder gekauft noch gespielt in letzter Zeit.
Aber ich tippe mal auf nein.
Richtig gutes Video.
Also ich meine, er hat ja schon 8 Millionen Aufrufe.
Das ist schon mal sehr nice.
Aber ihr könnt ja mal vorbeigehen und auch nochmal liken oder commenten.
Wir wollen uns jetzt hier nicht den Content rippen von YouTube.
Was hat denn der sonst? Ich kenne den überhaupt nicht.
Was hat denn der sonst noch so?
Instagramming of Dankmemes.
Okay, da noch mehr Zeug.
Also, das war ein richtig gutes Video.
Richtig nice.
Like, comment, subscribe.
Patreon, donation, alles.
Okay, was haben wir denn als nächstes Video?
Ich muss mal gucken.
Leute, ich gehe mal kurz aufs Klo.
Wenn ihr irgendwas habt, was wir noch gucken müssen unbedingt, schickt es mal.
Ansonsten nehme ich aus meiner Playlist das nächste.
Und dann sind wir, glaube ich, auch demnächst mal wach.
Okay.
Was soll jetzt bitte ein bisschen Clickbait, Prank und Challenges?
Oh ja, hauptetinkt.
Reaction, wir reacten einfach.
Wir gucken jetzt noch einen.
Nochmal ein ural Video.
11 Jahre, es wird ja immer älter.
Ist aber auch übelst lustig.
Ja, Leute, 480p.
Die sind ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die den neuen Assassin's Creed immer noch so durch die Menge laufen, wo sie alles untouchen.
Alter, das Typ, den hätten sie 100 pro heute schon instant verhaftet.
Da würde ich mich auch verpissen.
Alter, alles gut, alles gut.
Den hätten sie heute schon instant geschnappt und getasert.
Die waren echt ihrer Zeit voraus.
Würden sie heute so Videos machen, das würde voll durch die Decke gehen.
So.
Also ich hab gerade mal meine Playlists geguckt, ich hätte jetzt noch zwei Videos drinnen, die man gucken könnte und zwar einmal hätte ich was in Top 10 Insane Shits Happen at Gaming Tournaments.
Okay, anscheinend habe ich mir gedacht, das klingt interessant.
Oder Top 10 Sachen, you didn't know about Javascript.
Was wollen wir gucken, geht beides irgendwie 10 Minuten.
Es ist übrigens gar nicht Top 10 Javascript.
Was, Primitive Technology hat was Neues.
Primitive Technology, das...
Alter, mein Headset, Alter mein Headset.
Was ist jetzt los ey?
Hatte der das auch gerade, das ist übelst rumgespackt ey.
Ich habe jetzt übelst Geräusche im Headset ey, als ich das Video aufgemacht habe.
Ach, das sind die Videos, ja das kenne ich.
Der baut jetzt 10 Minuten lang, der baut jetzt 10 Minuten lang irgendwas.
Was baut er denn diesmal?
Ein Ofen.
Der hat schon verdammt viele Öfen gebaut.
Also gefühlt jedes dritte Video baut er dann ein Ofen, das kucke ich auch immer.
Find ich sehr entspannend diese Sorte von Videos.
Was ist das hier?
Bad shit crazy things happen at Gaming Tournaments.
Hier, hol mal.
Gaming Tournaments can be odd experiences.
But since we can't all go to them, we can't talk about what happens at them.
Sma 4K.
I'm Falcon and today on Gameranx, 10 Bad shit crazy things that happen...
Warum muss das Ding eigentlich Bad shit crazy heißen?
Klickt da mehr Leute drauf oder wie?
Wahrscheinlich.
Ach 2009, ach 2009, ja gut.
2009, ok.
Das war noch eine andere Zeit.
Was hast du eigentlich für eine Leitung?
Na ja, nachdem ich jetzt meinen VDSL bei der Telekom gekündigt habe, also das läuft jetzt noch eine Woche,
habe ich aktuell nur die 5 Mbit Up und 100 Mbit Down von Unity Media,
aber sobald das umgeschaltet wurde, werde ich upgraden auf 40 Up, 400 Down von Unity Media.
Na ja, das Problem habe ich nicht.
Wenn ich mein Herz halt aufhabe, lenkt mich nichts ab.
Das haben wir schon geguckt im Stream.
Das kennen wir schon, dass der Dude, der mit seinem Fuß spielt.
Aber immer noch geil.
Das haben wir immer noch geil, ey.
Das haben wir aber schon mal geguckt vor einem Jahr oder so.
Ok, Fighting Games kenne ich bis null aus.
Kennt man die Dude?
Ich meine, dass die Bühne überhaupt so weit unten ist, dass du mal draufjumpen kannst, ist auch schon mal merkwürdig.
Das ist aber nicht nur einer, da gab es ein paar.
Da gab es ein paar VAC-Bands von Intonieren.
Das hat echt fail.
Fuck.
Das schreckt.
Alter, die Japaner.
Die Japaner.
Da war schon gar keine Gedanken drum.
Vielleicht sollte man, vielleicht ist es ja auch eine Anregung für manche, dass sie sagen, sie streben eine Pro-Karriere in World of Tanks an.
Was? Was? Moment.
Ah ja, stimmt.
Stimmt, die hatten damals ja noch kein Replay.
Die hatten in StarCraft, muss ich das mal überlegen, die hatten ja noch keine Replay-Geschichte in StarCraft 2.
Das kam ja glaube ich erst mit einem zweiten Addon oder so.
Vielleicht ist da jemand auf einem besseren, besseren, laufenderen Stand als ich, was StarCraft angeht.
Mittlerweile haben sie das.
Sie hatten das Problem, dass du Matches, und das ist eigentlich total beknackt, Online-Turnier-Matches, wo, wenn die Verbindung zwischen dir abgebrochen ist, kannst du die nicht an der Stelle weitermachen, wo du aufgehört hast, sondern musst es komplett replayen.
Peep aheads.
Easy.
Das ist efftig.
Kann man nicht vorstellen, wie das funktionieren soll.
Weil ich meine, bei Fighting Games kommt es ja ganz extrem drauf an, dass du erst erstens das schnell siehst, verarbeitest, ohne schnell eine Reaktion hast.
Ah, das kenne ich.
Das kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Ich werde es jetzt gleich wie verrückt rum.
Was waren das, Ghosts?
Was, Ghosts?
Infinite Warfare?
Ach, genau.
Das kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Ich finde den Joke nicht bad, den Joke finde ich lustig.
Na gut, das ist gestellt.
Also Bad Shits Sachen in der Gaming Competition fällt mir jetzt nichts ein.
Sachen, die wirklich shit waren, fällt mir das Battlefield 1 Event ein.
Aber das ist ja keine Gaming Competition.
Ich fand den mit dem Fuß am besten.
Ja, ich auch.
Der Typ, der mit dem Fuß spielt, ist super.
Silent Pain hat noch was geschickt.
The worst CSGO Tournament ever.
Okay, das gucken wir jetzt noch, das geht nur 9 Minuten, das gucken wir noch.
Und dann muss ich mal aufs Klo.
This is the story of how one man's dumb idea created the worst tournament in esports history,
managed to piss off some of esports biggest teams and bankrupt his own company.
One land has lived in infamy as the worst event ever, the fire festival of gaming with missing computers,
confiscated passports and of course not a cent of prize money paid out.
Weißt ihr was mir gerade auffällt, Leute?
Wir machen Reaction Videos, wir machen ein Reaction Stream gerade zu Reaction Videos, die reacten.
Das ist Supermeta, ey.
The worst event that has ever happened to the point where people are literally grateful
to get out of the country with their lives, let alone their fucking prize money.
If you thought that iBuyPowerMasters or the Shanghai Major had problems,
let me introduce you to the gaming...
Ach, mir ist doch noch was eingefallen, was richtig Mist war, competitive.
Es gab mal von MSI, und nein, ich flamee nicht immer auf MSI rum, weil sie mich gebannt haben,
sondern in dem Fall haben sie es wirklich verkackt.
Sie haben mal ein Overwatch-Turnier gemacht, was nie stattgefunden hat,
was acht Stunden, acht Stunden, ne Warteschleife hatte, es geht gleich los.
Sag ich dir was zu...
Klingt schon wahnsinnig vertrauenserweckend, gaming.rs.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ist denn RS überhaupt für ein Top-Level-Domain?
Serbien? Okay, ich glaube ich war noch nie im Leben auf der Domain-RS.
Okay.
Klingt ja nach ganz toller Organisation.
Ach, ich glaube das kenne ich, ist das das Hotel, wo irgendwie einer am Ende dann eine Lebensmittelvergiftung von den Spielern hatte?
Ist das das? Da war doch irgendwas, wo die Spieler dann eine Lebensmittelvergiftung hatten, ist das das?
Ein Sturm?
Okay.
Das ist ja schon mal Fail. Was sollen sie denn spielen, von 8 Uhr morgens bis 24 Uhr nachts oder wie?
Was?
Der hat die PCs geklaut.
Oh Gott.
Das ist so teufel.
Let's Windows haben sie einen schönen Stage.
Ja, und was machst du mit den Leuten? Ich meine, da haben sich die Leute Tickets für gekauft, also eventuell.
Die Teams sind angereist für die Games. Wie sieht es mit Preisgeld und allem aus? Hallo? Du kannst das nicht ab gleichem Tag canceln.
Was ist das Schlimmste, was dir an einem E-Sport-Event passiert ist?
Dunsches.
Das ist noch schlimmer als Dunsches.
Moment. Die haben ein Event veranstaltet und die Sachen die sie gebucht haben, haben sie nicht bezahlt oder was?
Was?
Warum?
Ja, ist klar. Also spätestens jetzt hätte ich echt geguckt. Wobei, sie haben ja schon versucht sich aus dem Staub zu machen.
Es blieb ihnen ja auch nichts anderes übrig. Was sollten sie dann machen?
Haben sie das Geld jemals gekriegt?
Das wundert mich nicht, das wundert mich.
Wenn er das wirklich gesagt hat, wäre das echt eines der merkwürdigsten Dinge, an die er wahrscheinlich je gehört hat.
Ich weiß, wenn du danach pleite gehst, dann kannst du sonst wie viele Checks unterschreiben.
Das war wahrscheinlich auch nicht schwierig.
Oh Mann.
Okay Leute, es ist, wir sind jetzt eineinhalb Stunden on gewesen. 12 vor 12.
Ich glaube jetzt sind wir alle wach.
Nachher gibt es dann, wie eigentlich geplant, den Stream mit Nextcloud 16, wollen wir mal gucken ob das was taugt.
Ich gehe jetzt noch mal auf und mache ein paar Sachen.
Dann esse ich was und dann komme ich nachher wieder an.
Ich kann noch nicht genau sagen wann, ich denke mal so in 2-3 Stunden oder so.
Achso, MSI-Ban wollte ich noch was zu sagen, stimmt.
Ja, habe ich ja schon ein paar Mal im Stream jetzt auch gesagt.
MSI hat mich mal irgendwann auf Twitter gebannt, weil ich wahrscheinlich mich über ihre RGB-Beleuchtung lustig gemacht habe.
Vermute ich mal, ich weiß es bis heute nicht, was genau, was jetzt genau das Problem war.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Aber sie waren der Meinung, das war so schlimm und offensiv, dass ich mich über ihre RGB-Beleuchtung lustig gemacht habe, dass man mich bannen muss.
Vielleicht hosten wir noch irgendjemanden, zeige ich mal her, Twitch.
Hat eigentlich gestern noch jemand, den ich gehostet habe, den mit der Grafikkarte weitergeguckt, hat das noch geschafft das Ding umzubauen.
Ok, es gibt keine deutschen Science und Technology Streams so richtig.
Wirtschaft für Schüler EGIT, Wirtschaft.
Der Niko, der hosten wir nicht, der hat schon mehr Sachen, aber entscheidens noch zu geben.
Ok, wen haben wir denn noch auf Deutsch?
Wie hieß der, den ich gehostet habe?
Keine Ahnung, irgendetwas für ein Monster glaube ich.
Irgendetwas für ein Monster.
Ist das richtig, wir sind auf der ersten Seite mit dem Stream hier.
Die Uhrzeit ist kein Match-On so richtig.
Ok, keine Ahnung.
Hast du nicht damals sogar was zusammen mit Inscope gemacht? Ja, mit dem Niko und dem Benny war das damals, da war er aber noch nicht Lifestyle Fitness Channel.
Aussehen im Japaner.
Nee, ich haue es jetzt kein, ich gehe jetzt off und in 2-3 Stunden bin ich wieder da.
Was macht Benny aktuell? Keine Ahnung, ich habe jetzt nicht so das ich großartig Kontakt mit einem von beiden noch hätte.
Ich gehe jetzt off und in 2-3 Stunden oder so bin ich wahrscheinlich wieder am Start.
Und dann gucken wir uns Nextcloud an.
Ja, bis dann, machts gut, CU.